welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
and your money i'm dr john dolone here
with my good friend
and world famous co-host mr anthony
o'neill
anthony how are we doing hey man i i
really appreciate that intro man i mean
i didn't pay you for that i thought you
were a local talent you are not
you are worldwide john man you are
amazing right now keep going
i'm i'm i'm following in your footsteps
my good man you
blaze the trail but we are here to take
your calls on life
and money give us a shout at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five you got
anything planned
coming up no man uh right now it's just
a beautiful time
i'm enjoying the day enjoying tomorrow
looking forward to play some golf
tomorrow
and he knows last one in the last
weekends before we can actually
uh get into some cold weather and so i
don't play golf
with anything less than 50 degree
weather
so man i love sitting next to a good
fair weather
fan good fair weather sports person man
all right let's get to the phones let's
go to jonathan in pensacola florida
jonathan good afternoon how are we how
we doing
good afternoon gentlemen thanks for
taking my call yeah you bet how can we
help
i'm a 21 year old business and admin
student that is nearing the conclusion
of my academic career
and preparing to launch into full-time
work life
over the past two decades my parents
have helped me to build a substantial
savings account
into which i've placed every paycheck to
earn since i was 15 years old
i have no debt and have not owned a
credit card to date
i plan to after finishing college and
then willing and able to pay cash
for the vehicle my parents advised me to
reach out to you to inquire
if financing a small portion of the
vehicle purchase dollar amount
and paying it off soon thereafter would
be the best way to start building a
credit score
your advice is most appreciated ah man i
appreciate it
uh you sound like a very sharp young man
let's just say that educated um your
grammar is 10 times better than mine
20 times better than mine jonathan
you're an impressive guy you know i'm
saying you have a lot
how much money do you have saved up
right now jonathan
i have an excess of 20 000 in my savings
account
goodness gracious okay 20 thousand
dollars you're going to graduate
debt-free
yeah what kind of car are you thinking
about buying john yes
i'm thinking of buying a toyota corolla
my family is on those and it's a very a
wise decision from what i've seen
esteve toyota products are very very
reliable products what year you think
thinking about buying
i used by the time i would be buying a
vehicle it would be at least
two one or two years old i want to get
used so i don't get hit with
depreciation
wise man wise man so let let me ask you
this question
uh because your question is a fair
question and i want you to
think about this answer if you have
cash why do you need a credit score
good question uh my parents were talking
about uh to me because i have
plans alone eventually i'm currently
21 years old but i'd like to get an
apartment and like to buy a house
when i'm older and i know that you need
a credit score for both of those things
that's the reason for my question if it
would be wise to take out a small
loan for how i could pay cash
and just pay that off that way i can
start building a credit score at my very
young age
cool so let me help you out jonathan
when i was your age man at 21
22 years old my honest was about 18 19.
um i had a new mindset at 21. um i
thought the same thing that i have to
have a credit score one to be a young
man two to be successful three so i can
get an apartment
or um a mortgage and what i did just
like you
i said hey let me get a 500 credit card
uh
so i can be a young man so i can get my
credit score up
so i can get an apartment easy so i can
get a mortgage eventually
and that was the wrong decision for
myself and so
with you calling into the show i just
want to hit you up on on some game a
little bit
you do not need a credit score to be
successful number one
you do not need a credit score to get
an apartment number two and you do not
need a credit score
to get a mortgage now let me be honest
with you on the flip side
with you not having a credit score will
you have to put down maybe a little bit
more
money on your apartment yes instead of
you paying the first month rent you're
going to pay first month and last month
rent
and some people may require extra
deposit but that's fine because you sit
with money in a bank account
when you go grow up and you are ready to
get a mortgage
there are some things called a manual
underwriting or
non-traditional credit scores or no
credit score lending
and what these banks would do is they
will pull up your previous apartment
and ask you the proof ask you for proof
showing that you've
paid your apartment on time showing that
you've paid this on time
and so to answer your question uh
to be fair with your question no i would
go pay cash for the car
and instead of forgetting one to two
years i would do like a three to four
year old
car and that's what i just recently did
bought a four-year-old vehicle
and saved me a lot of money and then
from there here's how you're going to
win jonathan
because i think you're going to be a
homeowner within the next three to five
years
i am okay with you financing a home uh
when it comes to a 15-year fixed rate
and putting 10 to 20 down i want you to
keep the same mindset that you have
right now with saving your money
and living below your means and as long
as you come up with 10 to 20 percent
down
you will find a bank that will finance
you and give you a home
mortgage and you will have to look
around to find some apartment complexes
but john
this is the same mindset that a lot of
people have you know especially in this
age bracket that i have to have a credit
score
uh to be successful and and to get into
an apartment no
now there will be some that will tell
them no we will we cannot rent to you
and that's that's okay but there are
several apartment complexes when they
see you have no debt
you got 20 000 an account they will rent
to them that's right and
jonathan you are already setting the
stage for what's going to be an uncommon
life
yeah right you are a planner you are
thinking
things through you've got cash in the
bank it's a 21 year old you're going to
graduate debt free as a 21 year old
you are way you're already weird yes
right and so you're joining a gang of
weird people
living weird and i don't want you to
subscribe
to traditional living when it comes to
being a slave to the fico score getting
in line behind
everybody else doing the same things no
man you're different jonathan
and hey here's the deal your parents
love you they love you they're trying to
do the best they can by you and so
we don't need to hate on them we don't
need to say mom and dad you're an idiot
no they're not they're trying to the
best they can
and you called into the show and you got
some different wisdom you're way ahead
of the game man yeah
and tell your mom and dad to watch this
show watch this segment with dr d
and myself and then also to just go do
some research but i want to encourage
you brother
nearly 48 of the people in the world
today can't afford a 400
emergency this young man got 20 thousand
dollars sitting there account
i can guarantee you there are millions
and millions and millions of grown
adults
with families that don't have 20 000 in
a checking account
jonathan you're head of the game my man
yes i want to jump through the screen
screen and just hug you bro like i'm so
pumped right now young man with this
kind of money
get yourself a great he's already down
on the corolla man that's what i'm
saying
jonathan you got to start it off right
today listen america get a corolla
put some money in the bank this is the
dave ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and
interior shutters with easy online
ordering free shipping and a guaranteed
perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
doloni joined by my co-host and good
friend anthony o'neil
we are taking your calls about life and
money triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
let's go to jenny in seattle washington
jenny how are we doing this afternoon
all right guys it's good to meet you in
person
um i am a longtime listener first time
caller
and i have kind of an emotional versus
financial question for
you my mom passed away in september from
cancer and um thank you
it's it's been really hard to lose her
i'm an only child and we've always been
very close
and i've i'm also a single parent myself
and have been my son's whole life so she
was
a very strong goal for both of us
and um so that's that's been really
tough um
especially this year she did leave me
enough financially to pay off the
remainder of my debt
i was in that baby step and have maybe
about two years left on my own plan and
now i'm debt-free and have some
liquidity i didn't have previously
and is leading me to consider quitting
my job
i i love the job that i do i'm an
accounting manager but it's very
high stress and demanding and i've only
been able to take about
one week off after my mom's debts and
heading into my busy season it's just
it's overwhelming
um she also left me her house in
addition to
some liquid assets and trying to just
unwind her house
and decide what to do with it and get it
in order and just
find time to process grief i'm finding
myself considering
quitting and i'm a certified management
accountant
if i were to go get my master's degree i
could get my
cpa certified public accountant license
and move into public accounting which is
also very demanding but
built to better allow time off than the
private industry i'm in
and i just don't want to make poor
financial choices i i
doing what i do for a living i generally
know the best choices and listening to
the show but i'm
very emotional and urban in my decisions
right now and just wanted to call
in since you guys really cover both of
those ends of the spectrum
yeah well thank you so much for your
trust and for your call yeah let's start
with the money part here
yeah break it down from for me a little
bit more jenny how much are you getting
within
the inheritance yeah so liquid is about
hundred and fifty thousand three hundred
of that is in
an inherited ira so i'll have to drain
that over the next ten years with the
care back
yes and then the rest is just uh
brokerage and cash accounts
uh also looking me her house it's got no
mortgage on it and it's worth a little
under 500k i went ahead and had um
an appraisal done to protect some
capital gains in the future if i do
have to sell it but i emotionally i'd
like to keep it i just haven't thought
through
what makes sense with that yet um
so you're looking at almost a million
dollars an inheritance right now
between yeah yep house and she also
left behind um she she wrote knitting
pattern books for a living and so she's
left behind her digital assets
and the business and that they will
continue to
sell and at a lower volume than what uh
when she was alive of course but
that will be a continued income stream
in the future
yeah and so right now from a financial
perspective you're in a good healthy
place you said you're dead freak all
right
yep okay and you do you already have a
fully funded emergency fund
i do okay cool great and then you're
already living in a house that you want
to live in for the next few years
yeah now i have two houses all of a
sudden and that's i love it it's hard to
know what to do there
here's something i want to do here's
something i'm going to recommend that is
i believe it's really going to be up to
you
i think right now you have a great heart
i want john to talk into the emotional
side because i think the practical side
when it comes to the finances you have
now here's something that i would
recommend from a uh financial practical
perspective since she that's your mom's
house
and you want to keep that from an
emotional uh standpoint
rent it you know maybe fix it up make it
uh look real
nice you're sitting on 500 a thousand
dollars um
fix it up and rent it out let it
generate you and your family some income
then what i would do is i would jump on
the phone with one of our smart
investors and tell them hey
i got five hundred and fifty thousand
dollars three hundred this is gonna be
coming from a mutual fund
um and i just wanna make sure i gotta
pull it out but what can i reinvest that
into
uh to make me some more money we don't
have enough time to really dissect that
here on the phone call but i would
definitely recommend that you do that
but i mean and honestly take a little
bit of that and maybe
treat you and your family out somewhere
but i would definitely jump on the phone
and figure out out of this 550 what can
i do with 450 000 of that to turn that
into a million down the road
and then the 500 000 in the house you
know i'm gonna sit here
how can i fix that up a little bit get
it rentable and then rent that out and
allow that to generate
on some extra income for my family not
but before we do this we do have to make
sure we're in a healthy place
emotionally right so
jenny you said something that stuck out
to me and
i think it's going to be the foundation
by which you make all other decisions
and that is you got a week off yeah
and then you had to get right back into
it
and the guy who raised me on crisis
response
was also somebody that i went to as a
personal mentor
and when i had a personal tragedy i was
also in
um in the hunt for another job
and he gave me some wisdom that has con
i've continued to live by
which is now that you've had this
tragedy you will make
no major decisions for six months to a
year
yep until you're well because any and
all decisions you're going to make are
going to be
emotion-based decisions they're going to
be running from
not two right you found yourself flushed
with cash you have found yourself
in a unique situation that you didn't
foresee but you also haven't dealt with
the grief of your mom
and so before you go quit your job that
man you may have just
that may be a great thing to do you've
got cash to go get yourself a master's
degree to
to move yourself into a different
situation that'd be awesome
um but until you fully have that lined
out until you've actually
processed your mom's grief and it's not
going to go away in six months right
that's going to be a
you know an ongoing thing right until
you've got some
a platform for you and your your child
as a single mom until you've got those
things lined out
i recommend don't jump jump don't jump
ship
because i don't want you to find
yourself a month from now or two months
from now
the smoke is clearing from the crazy
season
right and yep you've spent some money
and you're
a semester into a graduate program and
then you're going to be thinking what
did i do
right and so do this
do you have a group of folks that you
can talk to do you have a friend
do you have a couple of folks that you
are in regular connection with out there
in seattle i do
yeah how have they supported you through
this
this time uh hearing me
literally hearing me talk it out and
that kind of thing
and support i my company's big enough
we're multi-state and have about 400
employees that there's
leave options in place
there is no backup for my role so i have
this intense sense of responsibility i
really
cling to the areas i own at work and
it's all deadline driven and tax filing
and audits
and year-end and i just i there's
literally no
person trained to cover that if i'm out
for more than a week and um i'm new in
my current role this year i've been
there eight years i've worked my way up
to this
i've had the same boss for that period
and he's been good and he's
newly in a cfo role and it's obviously
been a very challenging here for all
businesses so i have this
intense sense of not being able to let
go because there's nobody to unload it
on so
i feel as if those leave policies don't
apply to me but listen
listen the person you're
unloading it on is you the person you're
unloading it on
is your is your kid yep the person
you're unloading it on
is those men and women who love you and
care for you there in seattle
and so for the next few the next few
months
the next few seasons your work does not
get your first
fruits you do your work doesn't get your
heart and soul
your child does and that's going to mean
talking to your boss and having a if
he's a he's a new leader he's a new cfo
it's time for him to step up and he's
going to find out what leadership's all
about because his rock star
his anchor is going to come to him and
say i'm not well
i need to process my mom i need 60 days
i need 30 days and i know it's in the
year i know it's busy and i know it's
not it's an inopportune time
and you're going to find out if this is
the company you're going to work for a
long term
or this is a company that you don't want
to be a part of but it's right now
it's time for you to to turn the dial
back and look in the mirror and say
jenny's worth investing in my family's
worth investing in
and i need to grieve that wonderful
wonderful mom who raised me and cared
for me and my son
what a blessing spend some time on you
take that leaf policy
and let the rest go this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard
can help get you there plus they offer
unbelievable financial benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
doloni joined here by my co-host and
good friend anthony o'neal
let's go to rebecca out in buffalo new
york rebecca how's it going
hey i'm great how are you outstanding
how can we help today
good well i had a question about
boundaries i've listened to your show
quite a bit and i hear you talk a lot
about
setting boundaries especially with
family and especially around the
holidays
um but i was just wondering if you could
maybe address um
how to be on the flip side of that when
somebody sets a boundary
that makes the rest of the family kind
of uncomfortable and awkward
hey this is the first time i've ever
been asked the other side of the
boundary question
i love this rebecca anthony it's going
to be good all right go for it rebecca
well my sister um is kind of going
through like a
bit of a i don't know midlife crisis or
something and she's she's
made it very clear to the rest of the
family that she's not
willing to talk to any of us about
anything that's going on in her life and
we're not allowed to ask her any
personal questions at all
okay and so i'm
kind of dreading might be too strong of
a word but i'm not really looking
forward
to like thanksgiving sitting around the
table you know all of us all together
and none of us are allowed to have
a kind of conversation with her um you
know we got to constantly filter like is
this too personal
is she going to get mad if i ask this
what about this you know
what what about just not asking her
questions
that just seems rude well
it would be except that she told you
don't ask me any questions about my life
and is it going to be annoying yes and
is it fair for you to say hey we get
that you asked us not to do this
this is new for us and so we're going to
ask you to remind us
right because we're going to forget
we're going to stumble over this because
we love you and care about you
but we want to respect that you've said
don't ask us any questions and so we're
going to try
if we forget if we lean over during
dinner and we just ask this one question
and then just give us a hand signal say
i really don't want to talk about that
give us some grace and i think you
deserve that right
but at the end of the day it sounds like
she's made uh thanksgiving a little bit
easier
and she has said this part's off limits
and it's annoying and it's frustrating
but it kind of is what it is what do you
think anthony but rebecca i want to ask
this question too
what did she say is off-limits
specifically did she say her
life or this part of my life
um well i mean like we can talk about
like our childhood like
you know childhood memories and stuff
like that but it's just like
we're all concerned about her and what
she's going through is she dating
someone y'all don't like or is she
working at a job you don't like her
what's the thing we don't we don't know
um she's she's still she's still married
but she's not with her husband
um she moved to a different state and
i'm not sure what state
she has a job that i don't know anything
about um i don't even know what she's
doing right now
so here's a here's a great gift you can
give her
yeah and i hope everybody hears this
often when we love people and they're
going through pain
the way we love to lean into that pain
and this is this is coming from a good
place
most of the time not always but most of
the time
is we want to give them our wisdom our
experience and our advice
and one of the greatest gifts you can
give to somebody who's hurting
is your presence and just your
sitting next to them until they invite
you in to hey what should i do here
because my guess is your sister's
struggling with shame your sister's
struggling with
you her fancy sister rebecca's got a
great marriage and
everything's working out awesome and mom
and dad don't like fill in the blank
and so instead of leaning into hey i
really want to know what's going on so i
could help you
she has said in a roundabout way the way
you can help me is sit by me at
thanksgiving
and let's not get into that kind of
stuff i just want to be with you guys
the fact that she's showing up
i want to give her the benefit of the
doubt there the easier thing probably
would have been to not come at all
and so she's coming and the greatest
gift you can give her is
distraction laughter and warmth and
presence and my guess is
if you give her that those things equate
to safety
and when suddenly she doesn't feel
judged by you she feels safe
then she's going to slowly say hey
here's my situation
right and so the the challenge for you
is going to not be to bang your head
and your arms and legs and elbows and
knees up against that boundary that
she's put up
and instead 100 respect it
and just give her joy and peace
and once she invites you in then you can
slowly give your opinions and thoughts
and insights
what do you think anthony i'm gonna play
the devil's advocate on this for rebecca
okay
okay and i'm not and i'm saying this
because i'm just i'm just saying like
hey
i'm gonna put i'm putting myself into
your sister's shoes
yeah um one of the key things that i
like thanksgiving is coming up and so
i'm not looking forward to going to my
family's house only because of one
question
what's that one question everyone's
going to ask me john why are you still
single
that's right you know what i'm saying
and to me
my my respectful answer to them is it's
none of your business
so what if what if anthony you know what
i'm saying what if you
preemptively sent a note out to
everybody and said this year
i don't want to talk about being single
i love you guys and we're just going to
talk about
other things yeah and that's my thing
like yo let's just have a conversation
bro
man congrats on the book or hey man i
see you doing this like
talk about something that is like what
you said and inviting
that it doesn't make me feel shameful
because sometimes my family members
i know they have the right intentions
and that they love me but sometimes when
i hear when
you're single well maybe you need to do
a b there you go that's right
i don't want to come around you because
you want to give me your opinion but you
don't live my life
so we're saying the same thing yes we're
saying the same yeah and so what i'm
saying to you is rebecca like when she
comes
hug your sister you know embrace your
sister talk about your family talk about
you know how good god has been to the
whole family you know
if if she if her hair is different
compliment her hair girl what are you
doing in the gym you look good
give me that ingredient you know make
her feel accepted make her feel
welcomed and then i agree with john more
than likely she won't bring it up
this time because she's fearful um of
if she does bring something up then
everybody's gonna have an opinion
because that happens to me every single
thanksgiving and christmas
my mama my sister my brother my
brother-in-law
even now my nephews uncle anthony you
ain't married
you know what i'm saying so i don't want
it to come up
so your sister whatever hurt whatever's
going on in her world she doesn't want
to come
up you know why because i i want to
enjoy my family
and i i don't want to feel like the odd
one i don't want to feel like the one
that is
unhealthy in the situation because of
this current part of my life
so i would i'm not the expert this is
john's area i'm just you are an expert
because you experience it
right yeah you're in a practical
perspective like you know hey
sometimes we just want to go and just
laugh and just
eat all the turkey eat all the ham you
know and just be unhealthy for a chance
in a good way
so rebecca can you do you have other
brothers and sisters
uh yes there's a brother between the two
of us yep so here's what i want you to
do
i want you to take the lead on this one
yeah and i want you to reach out to your
brother
and say our sisters asked us not to talk
about certain things
we have one goal and that is to laugh
like we have never laughed before yes
come up with funny stories write them
down we're gonna proactively think of
funny things from our childhood
we're gonna proactively prank dad we're
gonna proactively
create an environment where she feels
safe she feels totally welcome
and here's the thing she may be involved
in things y'all don't agree with you i
don't like you're worried about her
if you create an environment of safety
she'll invite you in absolutely she will
eventually may not be that damn it
probably won't be
yeah probably won't be yeah but it will
circle back
and um and if it even if it never does
she has drawn a boundary and i love the
fact rebecca you just made my heart feel
good because all across the country
i've heard this over and over and over
people are for the first time anthony
drawn boundaries
yeah i'm worried about coving i'm not
coming or if you don't wear a mask i
don't want you at my table
or or or all these different boundaries
are being drawn for the first time this
year
and if you're input if you're i mean if
you're if your default setting is to
run up and shove that boundary and see
if it's going to hold you're just going
to bring tension to thanksgiving
we need no more tension yeah no more
attention
if somebody puts up a boundary even if
you don't agree with it or believe in it
honor them seek peace seek laughter
seek safety over thanksgiving rebecca
good for you you're a good sister
i love it this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey good folks it's the most wonderful
time of the year
believe it or not christmas is just
around the corner
i can't even believe that anthony
christmas is just around the corner
you heard it here first you heard it
here first
as though it's gonna pop up on the
calendar of a strange day no matter what
this year has brought you christmas is
still coming and to celebrate we're
giving away
cash all season long enter our ramsey
christmas giveaway
daily to increase your chances of
winning one of our weekly 500
prizes or our 5 000
grand prize enter at daveramsey.com
giveaway plus if you're looking for
life-changing gifts for friends and
families
we don't need any more plastic junk we
don't need any more
beepy things or any more screens give
people something that will actually help
their life get better our famous 10
sale is back and that means you can shop
over 50 of our
best-selling books and envelopes for
only 10
or less get books like my brand new
quick read
redefining anxiety if you're anxious or
you know somebody who is
10 bucks man you can solve it right like
that not really but
i'm gonna make that case or anthony
o'neill's number one national
best-seller
debt-free degree yeah for ten bucks ten
dollars ten bucks
i need to talk to dave ten bucks man you
can go to college
for free for ten bucks i don't even know
if that sentence works but i'm gonna go
with it
that doesn't work bro enter to win some
cash and save some serious money on your
christmas shopping today at
daveramsey.com
giveaway no purchase necessary to win
and you can
enter daily to increase your chances
very very cool let's go to amanda in
lexington
texas amanda how are we doing
i'm good how are you good deal how can
we help today
yeah my husband and i had an income
increase this year
which has allowed us to do a lot of our
financial goals
including baby step four let's go
wait so hold on amanda this has been the
worst year ever in the history of the
universe planet ever
yes but you got extra income what
happened
my husband completed his master's degree
and stepped into the position of nurse
practitioner
and oh boy way to go and you who've been
putting him through
grad school and full-time you get to
breathe a little bit now
well sorta but i had the fourth baby
this year so oh
amanda good for you guys you all have
been into it
so how much how much was your uh your
increase
um so we went from about 60 to about 98.
okay so we have a 98 000 household
income in the year of 2020 correct
yes yes okay so you've already maxed out
your babysitter number four which is
investing 15
of your gross income um into a
401k or into a growth stock mutual fund
invested into
ira correct yes okay how much this is
where we kind of had the
question because we're in a house right
now that we own i've been here almost
five years and
it we fit it's not
dire that we move but that is a goal um
hopefully in the next few years
but then also we have four daughters
and i think my husband is starting to
feel the crunch of saving for them
and so that's probably not the only
crunch he's feeling right now that's a
lot of women in that house huh yes
bless him he's a great girl daddy good
for him
yeah so just trying to figure out like
how to balance whether we stay for the
next down payment or even put like extra
towards our current mortgage
or whether to start accounts you know
for weddings and school and things like
that for the girls or
whatever to try to do both or
not and amanda i love this question uh
because i think it's a it's a fair
question to ask
and this is the prob probably the most
normal question we get
when people get a significant pay raise
they
immediately start to look at how do i
use this
okay and i i think on one hand it's a
fair question on the other hand it's
for me i'm not asking myself how do i
use this
i actually give myself two years in that
significant pay raise before i make a a
actual huge financial moves so prime
example when i came here
to join the speakers team my income went
up significantly
but i lived for literally about three
years
yeah about three years on my youth
pastor's salary before coming here
that's how i was able to do the things
financially i'm able to do now
so what i'm going to recommend to you
all is this how much money do you have
in a savings account right now
uh between 18 and 20 000. okay 18 to 20
000. if something was to happen
right now with your husband um is that
the minimum of three months
of investments oh yeah okay great sounds
like it's a little bit more so great
when we are already investing are you
already investing into your
your daughter's college fund no we
haven't started that yet
okay cool i would do that immediately
okay i will go ahead and start opening
up um
the how old are your daughters my oldest
is about to turn seven
okay seven and then what what's the next
one after that
then five five okay two
and then two months two months okay so
what i would do
is i would probably open up two 529s
talk to a smartvestor pro
uh because the seven and five year old
um are close so i would probably have
two that we can possibly invest into but
then the good thing about the 529s is
they can roll down to your kids to your
other kids
okay so before i look into purchasing
another home
i want to go ahead and start thinking
about legacy thinking about my kids
college
future and this way um once you start
funding that
then i would start looking at okay in
the next two years
husband um let's go ahead and start
looking into a home so once you start
funding this 529 the college uh
plan i don't have a problem with you all
going ahead and start setting aside some
extra money
to put down towards a home so here's a
good thing
start looking at the equity in your home
right now because you're going to sell
that to upgrade
and then also start looking at how much
money can you put down if you all can be
there within the next year and a half
two years that is great but what i want
you to do is make sure that you create
some cushion
because immediately when we get that
extra money john we
immediately want to spend that okay now
we got the margin let's go get a bigger
house no let's
let's make sure that when we get the
bigger house we still have that same
margin
because here's the thing america hear me
clearly
when it comes to building wealth it's
not your income
it's margin how much margin do you
have to survive to live and to press on
you can make a million dollars and be
broke you can make
a hundred thousand dollars and be
wealthy
and do me a huge favor amanda
seven five
two in two months is that right yep yes
i'm gonna tell you to do something that
i never do i i'm the super frugal one
right my brand new truck is an o6 right
i'm i'm
i'm annoying when it comes to being
frugal
okay but take a little bit of that money
and
you and your husband do something
special y'all haven't slept in close to
a decade now
agreed you got a two-month-old you don't
even know what day it is
you don't it's a and it's okay but for
real
for christmas hire somebody to come over
and be with those kids
and do something fun and lovely for one
another
um that's a lot you guys i want y'all to
celebrate this moment
because i know that when someone's when
a spouse is in grad school and working
full-time
not only are are they working hard but
the person who's
holding the house down is working hard
too and by the way you're growing a
human
and making sure the other three were
still alive during that time so do
something fun for each other
yeah but anthony i love what what you're
saying here
we just sprint to to collapse that
margin
yeah right collapse that margin i love a
story that dave has told us
privately and i'm sure he's told it on
the air too which is
it was the margin yes that in 0.809
when when things fell apart he was able
to go knock on doors and buy
land and buy homes with pennies on the
dollar because he had the margin
and that's and others didn't right
absolutely that's the thing that has
really helped
me out with the move that i just did i
had the margin to go buy
a home that in a gentrified area that
one day within the next year a year and
a half will become
a rental property for mine because i had
the margin
i took time i rented until i was 32 33
years old that's right because i wanted
to have
margin to really go build true wealth i
want to thank
producer james childs an associate
producer
the one and only kelly daniel the one
and only kelly daniel
thank you for joining us for this hour
this has been the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
the total debt is around six hundred and
forty thousand dollars
for the rest of my life i just don't
even know where to begin
and i don't know what to do i'm not
scared welcome to the dave ramsey show
you are not a victim you are the hero in
your story
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career everything just
started making sense
i was like i'm gonna do this let's hear
a debt-free scream
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out
to have a conversation about your money
and your life
i am john deloney here with my good
friend
and co-host anthony o'neal we're here to
take your calls about your relationships
your money your
life everything in between yeah anthony
how are we doing
i'm doing good man how are you doing man
you are just winning right now with the
dr john de lonnie show you dropping new
episodes every monday wednesday and
friday on youtube i mean you are just
really i mean your numbers are through
the roof let's just be honest we're
having some fun
no no no no you're so humble let me be
arrogant for you
[Music]
you're doing numbers like twenty
thousand thirty thousand fifty thousand
and even one of your videos got like
three hundred thousand views we're doing
good man and you're a rookie
uh hey trust me you can watch that show
and you can find out real quick that i'm
a rookie but what i'm saying is those
those are not rookie numbers man i'm
just excited to have you on the team
because here's what
america this guy is helping people and
helping people
get their mind and their mental
perspective correct
and so i just want to say live on the
air in front of 17 million people
thank you for what you do and it's so
cool to be on this team
so i'm grateful for you man you've
blazed the truth see my god he's like
yes
i agree with him anthony you know like i
like him i like man but honestly america
check out his show y'all check out his
show i appreciate you that's right so
give us a call at
and 825-5225-825-5225 we we're two men
here there should be no blessing
all right let's go to miller in athens
georgia miller how are we doing
doing well john ditto to what anthony
said thank you for everything you do
well i appreciate you how can we help
today
um so i have an 11 year old stepson
um he's been i've been his stepdad since
he was two and a half years old
um and i just feel like i'm not
being the stepdad that he needs um
i get i'm a little harder on him than i
am on my actual biological kids and i
can i can tell
um he was diagnosed with adhd a few
years ago
we've got on some good good medication
for while he's at school
to help him control his impulses he's
very
impulse he doesn't really have a great
inner monologue
but he's he's he's just full of life
he's great he's
been uh inventive he wants to be an
engineer he loves to build things but
i know i'm harder on him than i should
be and
i just want advice um on how to be a
better step-dad
now hold on hold on miller
explain to me why do you think you're
harder on him give us an example
of why you think you're harder on him
than you are to your son
um i know that
there's sometimes so he can be a little
argumentative which
i mean he's an 11 year old boy he's
getting close he's probably
starting puberty and getting that way
but he does he does
question things a little bit more um
than
than what i would probably like and um
sometimes i don't really
i jump on him before i let him
him talk or um you know i get i just get
on to them a lot sooner and
and then i probably should my wife has
tried to talk to me you know i need to
pick my battles and things like that
which i feel like i've gotten a lot
better at but
um you know i i just want to be want to
be better for him i want him
to look back when he's in his 20s and
say
you know thank you for for being my
stepdad instead of looking back and
resenting me
thinking that you know i'm i i wish i
had had somebody else or i wish i was
able to live with my my
real dad or or anything anything like
that i just
i know i could be better for him so i
miller i want to
just tell you um dad to dad
i'm honored to be talking to you today
and if every father in america much less
stepfathers
had the heart you have have the desire
to
want to raise a remarkable young man
the way you do the world would be a
better place
and so just the fact miller that you are
asking this question
is a gift okay the second thing is um
let me ask you a couple of questions one
is his real dad in the picture
he is um he lives about three hours away
from us
so and he his dad is um in the medical
field
um so he is busy a lot
um and he doesn't get to see him as much
as as i know
my stepson would like but yeah he he's
in the picture he facetimes he talks he
calls we have a great relationship
so yeah he's still very much in the
picture what other kids are in the house
um his i have a 12 year old daughter
and then we also have a three-year-old
little girl and a one-year-old little
boy
very cool so a like a good blended
family here
with a dad two dads who've chosen to be
grown-ups
and to honor each other for the sake of
these kids
um man you are so far ahead of the curve
miller
um here's a couple of things i can tell
you i haven't gone through this
i've walked alongside people but i
haven't experienced it and anthony
you've lived this as that little boy and
so i'd love to hear your insight
here's a couple of things i would tell
you about being around a young boy who
is
11 or 12 and is struggling with adhd
and is connecting with his dad number
one
relationship with your daughter is going
to be different than with your son
and so i would hesitate i'd give
yourself some grace in comparing the two
it's easy to compare it thinking it's
biological but there's also going to be
a gender gap there and so give yourself
some grace
lean into high touch high connection
with this boy
as opposed to high information
the temptation that especially men when
they're trying to raise other men
we only have a few tools in our tool kit
most of the time
and those are volume and
strength and information
and one of the greatest gifts we can
give to a young boy especially one who
has um processing challenges which is
what adhd is just a processing issue
it's a connection issue is letting him
know every day
hey i chose to be your dad
i met your mom and you came with her and
i
chose to be your dad and i'm so glad i
did if you will say
that sentence to him for the rest of his
life he will grow roots
deep deep roots if you will say every
morning
hey before you leave before you go
upstairs to zoom school or whatever
y'all are having to do there in athens
come give me a hug and you squeeze him
hard and say i'm so glad i get to be
your daddy
i'm so glad that i chose to step in here
and be your dad
and then remember this third thing here
every time you're about to
cut him off every time you're about to
give him information
every time you're about to scold him
remember this
he is watching you way more than he's
listening to you
and so if you want to model for him what
a caring husband looks like what a
caring dad looks like what a
compassionate
father figure looks like
then i want you to remember that you're
you're you're giving him a picture as
opposed to what
what your what the words you're coming
out of your mouth right and so do this
miller i want to get anthony's take on
this i'm going to hold you over the
break
because i want to follow up here because
i've got some academic info but
anthony's walked this walk
so stay tuned miller this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
the medical bill sharing from chm was
exactly the way the website described it
there were no surprises no bait and
switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs
we like that it's a non-profit ministry
and that we were being better stewards
of our money
all while helping other families
established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm
is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
get started today and check us out at ch
chministries.org
backslash budget that's chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
dolone joined here with my co-host
anthony o'neal
we're talking to miller in athens
georgia
and miller is a step dad he's got a
biological
daughter he's 12 years old he's got a
wonderful
energetic exciting stepson who's 11
years old
and he just called in because he wants
to be a better stepfather what are some
things he can do to be a better
stepfather is that about right miller
that's correct it's awesome so
before the break i gave you a couple of
thoughts about
looking at adhd as a connection issue
it's not a brain disorder your son's not
broken
he's been through a lot and normally
kids who have been through a divorce
season your daughter's probably
experiencing this too
quite honestly just it manifests itself
differently in different kids
is that kids backfill that tension in
the home with it must be my fault
somehow
and it it will manifest its way in
perfectionism kids who double down on
straight a's it will manifest itself
in excitability and i'll get your
attention through
movement through shaking through being
allowed so on and so forth
and you are as far as i'm concerned dad
of dad of the year
just for even asking the question and
often
and we often men lean into little boys
with
information and strength and
focus and discipline and little boys are
just like little girls and they
need connection so we talked about
connecting with your young son
but i'm blessed here to have anthony
with us who has lived this he's walked
this walk
and so anthony when you're hearing me
talk to this this dad when you're
hearing this extraordinary father here
let us know what's going on your heart
and mind yeah you know
right before the brave man i'm glad i
didn't go before the break because this
is kind of an emotional
um conversation for me like it even
brings tears to my eyes because my
stepfather
and stepmother um i refuse to call them
step parents uh my parents
i have four loving parents who i look at
them all equally
um and miller i want to ask you a
question man i want you to be honest
with me
do you love him the way you love your
son that you actually birthed
absolutely do you
feel as if even a slightly
a little difference like okay yeah
that's my son and that's my stepson i
love them but you know that's still my
son like
you can say here on the show in front of
17 million people
and not just us but in front of god that
you genuinely love
that young man just as much as you love
your other son
i do genuinely love him cool i do
then what i want you to do is for
yourself stop calling yourself
a stepfather because there's nothing
step about you
you are a father and i think that
um one of the greatest things that both
my
other parents did was they showed me
love
more than told me how much they love me
and especially on my other mother i
treated her
like crap and she was there from day
one my my father other father
was the first man that i knew because my
biological father
was fighting overseas and to this day
i heard you say something earlier that
you want your son
to get in his 20s and say thank you
pops thank you pops miller and i can
assure you
that before he's in his 20s he will say
thank you
dad if you just sit there and you just
love him
um don't even bring up adhd because i
tell america this
uh the world said i had adhd because i
was just like your son
you know i was i have a lot of energy
still to this day some people looking
like is this boy crazy
like is he sick no i just have a lot of
energy and i got to remind myself that i
have to focus
and my mom was like maybe we should put
him
on medicine do you know who told my mom
no not my other dad my
stepfather my other father and he said
no we are not going to do that there is
nothing wrong with anthony
he is going to be okay i am going to
step up
i am going to be on him harder than
yvette which is my sister
harder than my brother which is my
younger brother john
you know and i'm gonna make sure that he
is okay
and that's why in my book debt-free
degree the first chapter is
proper prior planning prevents poor
performances
because my father other father would
wake me up
every night and would make sure that i
was
focused and that i was focusing on my
future
and so miller we don't have to tell you
how to be a better father
because you're you are already a great
father i think this call was to
encourage you
and all the other fathers out there who
are stepping up to the plate and filling
in that role as the biological father
that you all keep doing what you're
doing
and right now you may not feel
appreciated right now you may
feel like you're not doing enough but i
promise you you're doing
more than enough and before this
young man graduates high school he will
look at you in your face
and say thank you for the role you've
played in my life
as a father and i'm trying not to cry
because you i might hang up this phone
and call my daddy my other daddy
and tell him thank you because to this
day
i am that man uh and i am a man because
of uh the roles that all four of my
parents have played and so
uh miller man i um how old are you kids
uh 12 11 3 and 1. cool man because
because because
i just love what you're doing man i'm
going to um say on the phone i'm going
to send you a copy of my book debt free
degree
because you got young kids that need to
go to college debt free
um and with everything that you're doing
right now i believe that you'll do that
so stay on the line with kelly
that's my gift uh from you because i
wish i could do so much more man
uh because thank you anthony yeah man we
need more fathers like you
so miller we are in a season of thanks
and it's a it's a great time for you to
do this one exercise tonight i want you
to
write a letter to this little boy
and i want you to prepare to read it to
him
on thanksgiving and
while you're at it go ahead and write
one to your daughter go ahead and write
one to your wife
and i want there to be a new um a new
you know uh a new tradition in the
miller household
and that's where dad stands up and says
i'm grateful
for the folks sitting around this table
and here's why wow
and if you're like me i'd have to write
it down because i couldn't get through
it just off top of my head i'd start
crying
two seconds in and that would be it for
me yeah yeah but i want you to lean into
that
and i want you to let that little boy
know i'm so
grateful that i chose to be your dad
i'm so grateful and you know what
can i add something you can add anything
you want to can i change that a little
bit absolutely
sure yep and if this sucks tell me it
sucks okay
instead of for giving it to him on
thanksgiving give it to him when he
graduates high school
i think both i like that little boys
can't hear enough that their daddies are
super proud of them that they love them
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i would say
yeah i would definitely do that because
when he's 17 18 he can really understand
that more
that's right and to all the dads out
there remember remember
they're watching you way more than
they're listening to you yes they're
watching you way more than they're
listening to you
yeah and i want to say this too right
here on the dave ramsey show
we just praise all the fathers and step
father stepping up
if you're a father and you're not
fathering
you need to step up if you have
kids out there that you're not helping
the mother take care of them
you need to step up because the reason
why young men are just making some of
the poor decisions
in the world today not just young men
but young ladies it's because of the
lack of
fathers well even more than the lack of
fathers
is the dads who have been stressed out
fried out burned out by kova this year
you're exhausted you're worrying about
your job you're worrying about this and
this and your temper's gotten shorter
and shorter and you've started treating
yourself poor and poor and that
makes it easier to spend another night
in front of netflix another night
in the recliner another night
disconnected from your kids they're not
praising
be present whether you've just abandoned
them completely
or you are alone in a crowded room in
your home
this is the season to turn it around be
an engaged dad be a dad that says i'm
sorry be a dad that says i'm gonna do
better be a dad that says i'm so
grateful that you're my kids yeah
so grateful you're my kids this is the
dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and
interior shutters with easy online
ordering free shipping and a guaranteed
perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color
we'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more
use promo code ramsey to get the best
deal
rules and restrictions apply all right
anthony today's question comes from
jessica in new york
jessica writes i've been working through
baby step two
and i'm exhausted i'm currently working
six days a week and i've had a series of
murphy issues happening besides covit
such as pest issues car repairs that
i've had to cash flow
i'm so tired of the schedule and working
a job i
hate to pay debt how do i overcome
exhaustion
and depression while in baby step two
well you know when it comes to you know
the exhaustion depression part i want
you to talk into that but
for me uh i want to respectfully say
uh jessica um welcome to life i mean
everyone's being hit with all kinds of
things from covet this year i've had
some car issues come up um i haven't had
any pest issues but i've had a lot of
different issues come up
and the key thing that i've learned from
myself is to
instead of allowing me to get
overwhelmed with this just to sit down
and write down the priorities okay
what do i need to take care of first
what is priority
and just go down that line i think a lot
of the
exhaustion depression um anger
comes from self-inflicted stuff it's
like hey okay listen
you're on baby set number two so you're
paying off your debt
this means you should have a thousand
dollars an emergency fund
uh pest issues and car repairs as you
say you've already had a cash flow
you know um the pest issues you don't
want mice and stuff running around your
house so you need to get that fixed
so it's okay to pause babysit number two
go to your thousand dollars emergency
fund
take care of this past issue get your
thousand dollars back up and then jump
back on the baby step two
one of the key things that i think is so
important to hear
um and john i really want you to talk to
the exhaustion and depression side of
this
but from the baby step perspective is
we know something's going to come up
that is
life when it does come up just
just just step back breathe and attack
what's important and then just go down
that list
and then get right back going to the
baby steps
so anthony i had this moment the other
night my wife and i and i'm going to get
choked up here
um you shall argue no no my wife and i
put the kids to bed
oh wow and we were read the books we did
the whole thing
the you can picture my house the lights
are out my wife
head to the bedroom and i was piddling
around in the kitchen with one
light bulb on it's a dim lit kitchen
and i heard my son's door open and i
started to roll my eyes thinking oh here
we go another bedtime issue
you know what i mean i'm gonna ask him
what are you doing up and he's gonna
give me some excuse we're gonna go on
that
down that rabbit hole and he turned the
corner and i saw his face and he had
tears running down his face
i said bubba what's wrong and his school
had just been shut down again
oh wow and he just came walking fast to
me
and hugged me and said dad when does
this stop
wow when does this stop
when does school getting shut down and
not being able to go to church and not
being able to
not being able to hang out my friends
and you and mom are worried and stressed
and thanksgiving
when does this stop yeah and
jessica i hear what you're going through
everybody is exhausted yes they're just
fried
yeah right yeah and that's
when my son had an important advantage
he had other people and i tell folks all
the time anthony
other people are your emergency fund for
life yes you've got to have other people
because in these moments when you become
over overcome with exhaustion
tireds in your head exhaustion's in your
soul that's right
when you get exhausted that's when you
call somebody and you say i can't do
this anymore and they say yes you can
yeah well they say i'm all put together
a frito pie
and i'm gonna i've got half a bottle of
wine i'm coming over yeah right i'm
gonna put something on your doorstep
because we're not supposed to be hanging
out or whatever it is
and i also want to lean into this word
depression
we live in a culture now that we have
sucked all of the nuance
out of it we've sucked all feelings out
of it we used to have sadness
frustration
anger rage we just have all these
emotions now we got anxiety and
depression that's it
and so be careful throwing that word
around because i like what you said
anthony unless you've got a diagnosis
unless you were working with a doctor
you're probably not depressed you're
probably just sad
yeah you're probably this just sucks
you're probably just
exhausted and worn out and you need
other people
to pick you up to be there for you to
lean into you a little bit and then it's
your turn is going to come
right your turn is going to come but
this is life this is hard
i want to flip this around jessica and
high five you
you're in baby step two you had pest
issues you had car repairs
and you didn't just pull out a credit
card there you go you cash flowed it
it's hard to see that you're winning
when you're in the middle of it but you
are
you're taking steps in the right
direction they're little steps not near
as fast as you want
you are exhausted get some people around
you who love you
and keep going and keep going and keep
going as dave always tells us he reads
the
story the tortoise in the hair every
year and every time he reads that book
the tortoise wins yup one step after
another just keep going
we're with you we're with you jessica
all right let's go to christian
in mcallen texas christian how in the
world
are you let's see here uh whoops i went
to chris in atlanta sorry chris
um chris in atlanta i saw chris and then
i hit the wrong button there
chris but we're we're going to you chris
so what's up brother
uh not much guys there we go good deal
doing good
um so this has got to be god's head
because y'all are the food that i was
aiming to
get to talk to i've been listening to
y'all's podcast for
about four weeks now four weeks a long
drive home every day
and uh so my question is
i'm on board man i'm all hyped up about
starting
i sold my four-wheeler for baby step one
um sold my toys um and i'm all high
stuff but my wife
uh we're on two completely different
so she is not hyped up she's dave
ramsey's cuss word
um every time we talk about it we argue
about finances um and where it's been
from for her
is from the past a year ago
quickly found out she had cancer
and four months later she was gone
and she's in this mentality of you know
she's living for the moment
and you know she doesn't you know
she doesn't want you know to sacrifice
you know
anything in order to you know not do
certain things like vacations or
something
and it all kind of comes from you know
her mother passing so soon
and i don't know what to do
well one christian first and foremost
thanks for being a husband who loves his
wife and thanks for reaching out
appreciate you and all right guys that
tells me you got
you got a good heart around you and that
you love your wife
anthony what do you tell couples as
they're wrestling with how are we going
to get on board together
[Music]
i don't really talk to a lot of married
couples um
because you know but here's the thing i
do want to
suggest um is this
chris i would look at how you are
presenting it
and i can understand why
another man's name who doesn't live in
this house
is like a cuss word uh because dave
ramsey's name
will not be stronger than anthony
o'neill's name in my house
okay and so i think that how we present
a better financial future is is
is the wise way to go so instead of her
saying babe dave ramsey says
obey dave ramsey would suggest no just
say bae hey
can we become debt free i you want to go
on a vacation i want to take you
on the best vacation instead of going to
florida we need to go to
italy but we can't go to italy racking
up a bunch of debt so my suggestion is
dr john
is that how do we package this
um this conversation to where it's more
attractive to his wife
and that way she will get on board and
then here's what i am going to say
i'ma say this if your wife never wants
to get on board
uh this plan is not worth you losing
your marriage over
your marriage is the number one priority
okay and i believe together they can get
there though that's right chris it's
about painting a picture just like
anthony said here's where we want to go
here's where we want to be that might be
you being vulnerable and say hey all
this debt scares me
that might be you opening up to your
wife in a way you never have
but it's about painting a picture about
where you want to go
not about what you're running from i
love what anthony said not about what
dave's gonna make you do
about who we are gonna become together
on this new adventure going this way
and your heart's in the right place
brother yeah this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
doloni joined with my good friend and
co-host anthony o'neal
you're taking your calls on life and
money
now let's go to christian i'm gonna hit
the right button this time christian in
mcallen texas
how are we doing christian i'm doing
well uh john thank you
for uh taking the time to talk to me
today and for hitting the right button
this time so how can i help hey yeah
yep um so i've been down
uh in texas for about almost a year now
i've been deployed
or mobilized with a kentucky national
guard and i'm 19 years old
i have been investing the entire time
i've been down here i've put away
about 35 000 and i've had a tremendous
year i've made about twenty four
thousand in the stock market
i'm doing long-term uh five-year
outlooks on all the companies i invest
into
my question is i'm about to be home in
about a month now
and i'll be starting college i'm going
to
uh university of kentucky for a finance
degree to be a financial advisor
and i wanted to know until next fall
should i be going out and looking for
just job experience or should i just
keep on that grind of
making money and investing it while i
can at a young age
christian how are you paying for school
bro uh the kentucky national guard's got
it covered
i've got my tuition completely covered
and after this deployment
i'll have what's called the 911 gi bill
and they'll actually
be giving me around 700 a month to go to
school i love it
i love it i love it i love it so your
main question is
what should you be doing between
deployment and
going to school and so what are your
options right now to work and continue
stacking money
or what what's your other option just to
go out and look for experience
get better at sales just build up those
uh crucial life skills and business
skills because
i also like to run my own business one
day okay so i like two of these things i
i think you can do both of them at the
same time
i'm saying work stack up some money
so you can invest some money because you
already have 35 000 saved
i would sit down with smart investor pro
and see how you can you start sending
some money into like a growth stock
mutual fund
uh covered by ira to start investing
into your future would you say you're
already doing that so i will
continue doing that and start investing
a little bit more into that
but here's the flip side um i'm not
really concerned about the actual
um trying to get the
work experience i want you to network i
want you to get out there and build
relationships in the career field that
you're trying to get into
ken coleman wrote a book that you need
to read and i want you to stand on the
line because 19 years old 35 000
saved you deserve a free copy of king
coleman's book because it would bless
you
it's called the proximity principle and
one thing ken talks about is
if you really want to land your dream
job you need to be around some of the
people who are doing
what you already want to do so don't
focus on trying to get a job no
get around the right people this way
if you're building those relationships
tell them hey can i just come sit down
with you for a day and just see what
you're doing and
just build a relationship with you and
learn some things from you yeah son
come on over you know find two or three
people and just build that relationship
take them out to coffee man you got
enough money saved
and just ask them a bunch of questions
and when they talk you listen
and you just keep asking questions and
show them that you're hungry
show them that you're passionate tell
them you're about to go to school to
learn this
and what you'll find is when you go to
school and you get that education you're
going to have three people
who are willing to put their name on you
and vouch for you
okay so that's what i would really do
work a little bit over here so you can
generate some income
and then on the flip side really focus
on trying to build some business
some business relationships that will
benefit you in the future so
i want you to stay on the line kelly's
gonna give you a copy of ken coleman's
uh book proximity principle and then
also
too i think you need to listen to king
coleman's show monday through friday
because he will definitely walk you
through the process and the journey
on how to land your career job he's the
number one career expert in the us right
now
all right let's go to caitlin in
pittsburgh caitlin how are you doing
good how are you guys good thanks for
hanging out with us what can we do to
help
yeah thank you for taking my call so um
i just got accepted into medical school
for next year
congratulations um thank you
and uh i just worked really hard the
last two years to pay off my undergrad
debt because i
did the typical thing of taking about a
lot of loans and going to a private
school
and i'm trying to not do that
with medical school since like the
medical school debt is a big
conversation nowadays so i just wanted
you guys's advice on whether or not
you think it's a good investment or what
are some tricks or
ways to avoid medical school debt well
there's
there are no tricks let me just be real
to caitlin all right
um one of the key things that i'm
teaching people is to
stop saying i'm trying to not take out
student loan debt
and just go ahead and take debt off of
the table completely
so when you take debt off of the table
completely it's going to force you to
look at different options
okay so let's go down that path okay if
i'm not going to take out student loan
debt
student loans out of the picture what
are your options and let me tell you
right now
it's not going to be a lot and it's
going to be hard
okay but you can do it now you said
you've already been accepted into a
school
what school have you been accepted into
and how much is it going to cost you
uh yeah so i got into my school in
atlanta
and they gave me an academic scholarship
of 50
tuition it's just the other half i'm
worried about cash flow because
i just paid off all of my undergrad
loans okay
and how much is that how much is going
to cost you uh let's say a year to cash
fill that
how much will you need a year um a year
is looking at like
25 000. okay and how much do you make a
year right now
uh 70 000. okay and do you are you
living on your own
are you living with family um i'm living
on my own
okay all right so let me ask you this
question
if it's hard if you can pick up a side
hustle
if you can get online and find some
scholarships let's say for example you
can find another ten thousand dollars
and i'm giving my website
and if you really do the work i promise
you you can find at least 10 000
scholarship can you cash flow the other
15 000
i i believe so i i'm doing the baby
steps right now because
i i'm a recent listener so i don't have
a lot of credit card debt i have about
like 500 left on a credit card
and then i'm in a lease that i'm trying
to get out of
so definitely if i work on that aspect
i think i can do it i'm just worried
about the next three years like after
this additional year because
i won't be employed obviously after this
year okay all right so here's the thing
here's the next question gotta ask
yourself it's gonna be a hard one is it
time for you to go to medical school
right now
that's the question that you gotta ask
and then you have to be honest with
yourself
now let me give you some things that
that i'm seeing working
there are certain states there are
certain hospitals in certain states that
are low
on nurses doctors nurse practitioners
that if you can go to those states if
you're willing to
transfer for two years if you go over to
my show the anthony
show on youtube i interviewed two
doctors that went to school
100 debt free because they were willing
to go to a rural
area and serve in that community
and that hospital paid for their medical
and their medical degree and so maybe
going to school right now is not the
best option
but if you're really looking for it from
scholarships to possibly moving to a
a state or a city that you may not want
to be in so you can get your experience
so you can get your degree and then come
back to your state or city after like
two years
that might be an option but if you're
having a if you're telling me you can't
cash for fifteen thousand dollars
then we have an income problem that we
need to address first
then we need to look at the medical
school make sense
right yeah that makes sense yeah so i i
would ask yourself
and honestly have a hard conversation
with yourself you don't have to answer
it here on the show
because i i think that's something you
really need to ask yourself look
yourself in the mirror
is it time for me to go to medical
school right now and if the answer is
no take a year pay off the rest of your
debt
and then if you're making 70 000 your
income should go up next year to 75 you
can cash flow 25 000
and be done with your program within the
next two to three years and anthony you
hit on an important point when it comes
to law school when it comes to med
school
people get so excited when they get
accepted yeah they will just get in line
and do any next thing
yeah and you can ask for a deferral you
can't say
hey i got in i got this scholarship i
want to roll it over start next year
yeah and now i'm going to crush
to answer your question 25 000 a year
for med school is a good deal that's a
good roi on that
had the cash to figure it out thank you
so much for the call
go to med school and do some good things
for some good folks we need you
this has been the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
the total debt is around 640 thousand
dollars i
want him to come clean about a credit
card that he doesn't know about i'm
gonna probably pay
student loans for the rest of my life i
just don't even know where to begin
and i don't know what to do i'm not
scared welcome to the dave ramsey
you are not a victim you are the hero in
your story
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career everything just
started making sense
i was like i'm gonna do this let's hear
a debt-free scream
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
and your money i am john dolone
and i'm here with my good friend and
co-host the one and only mr anthony
o'neill
we are taking your calls about life
about money
about any and everything give us a call
at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five anthony we doing well
hey man we're doing well man ready to
get to these phone lines to help some
people out
outstanding let's go to elizabeth in
albany new york elizabeth how's it going
good how are you guys we are doing well
we're doing well how can we help
so um my husband and i were in 140 000
in debt a hundred of it is just in
student loans
and we're currently in baby step two and
on top of this two years ago
we had our first son welcomed into the
world and he was born with down syndrome
and shortly after his birth i became
very ill
and am now dealing with a chronic
illness um
i'm just feeling very guilty about our
current situation as i feel like a lot
of it
is my fault in a lot of ways and we're
working at our
at our debt but um at the same time my
husband and i are both working full time
so who do you feel guilty towards
i just feel guilty because i mean of our
student loan debt 80 000
is mine alone i got my masters in
finance and accounting
and um i just feel guilty because on top
of that i got like very ill
where i was debilitated and basically
working with fevers at home
trying to keep it together and i feel
like i mean the illness i feel like it's
my fault and on top of that
i had a son born with a disability
so what's your what's your illness
um i went on diagnose with lyme disease
and take born relapsing fever for two
years
and it also put my body into like an
autoimmune type of illness as well
and i'm currently at home getting home
care
i have a nurse coming weekly on iv
antibiotics
and on a whole other host of medications
as well
so i want you to picture
your life as a backpack
okay so you're wearing a backpack
and in that backpack we all have one but
we're just talking about yours today
and in that backpack are bricks
that you may have put in there over time
that your parents may have put in there
that your
religion or culture may have put in
there that
your financial stat state wherever you
happen to live
life puts them in there right and some
people are born with more bricks in
their backpack than others
some just skate free for a while but
everybody ends up with bricks in their
backpack
okay and then you do something that
violates
your core moral principles right
and you that's a cinder block right or
somebody somebody introduces trauma into
your life and they just
slam a cinder block into that backpack
and you carry it around for a while
when people talk about guilt for me
that's when somebody
violates one of their own core
principles they violate
their own conscience and there is a
proper and right thing to do when you
violate your core set of values and
that's to pick up and carry this brick
i made a mistake i'm going to carry this
for a while
when it becomes shame is when you put it
in your backpack and you say i
am a mistake i'm going to carry this
around because i have to
when you have a beautiful wonderful baby
that has downs but it's still lovely
and hard and challenging
and different i want to change your word
from guilt
to grief not that you're grieving that
you don't have a healthy baby that
also has down syndrome but you have a
baby that is different from the picture
that you had in your head
and i want to give you permission to say
this isn't how we drew it up
this isn't the picture i the fantasy i
had in my head and it's okay
and i love love my baby
and i love this new adventure we're
gonna be on together and that's
different than
guilt it is a real thing that moms and
dads who have children with special
needs
feel like they quote unquote did
something to somebody the longer you
carry that brick around
the more you weigh yourself down the
more you weigh your marriage down and
the more you weigh your parenting down
and here's the thing you've got an
autoimmune disease
you owe it to your body to sit down as
many of those bricks as possible yeah
did you borrow a lot of money for school
yeah
you did and then you learned and i guess
you learned some new information
right you learn some new information
yeah and so carrying it around to
tomorrow into the next day and the next
day only does one thing
it traumatizes the next day and the next
day the next day and the one thing your
body needs
is as few bricks as possible
right right so i wanted to tell you you
are worthy of walking around
with a lighter load you are worthy of
putting those bricks down that you've
picked up and chosen to carry
you've got a baby that is different than
your than you thought
but wow what a gift right
oh yeah beautiful fun messy
fun gift right it's different but it's a
gift
and is your husband a good guy and i oh
yeah oh my gosh she's amazing
and the guilt more i mean i don't
i don't feel like i mean for a while i
did blame myself for what happened but
it turned into more of a guilt like i
can't stay home with my child
because of my student loan debt and
here's the thing
you've acknowledged it you pick that
brick up and i want you to set it down
because all you're doing now is
prolonging the gap
between you and your child prolonging
that gap between you and your husband
because you got a big cinder block
between the two of you put it down
it is what it is and what you're going
to do is you're going to do the best you
can
is as much as your health will allow to
grind the sucker out you're going to pay
that stuff off as fast as you can
and you and your husband are going to
live towards something anthony talks a
lot about this you're going to live
towards a future where you're staying at
home
you're soaking up every precious minute
with this beautiful
wonderful baby and you are doing the
best you can right now to grind it out
the more you drag yesterday into today
the more
that smells just gonna going to wrangle
your whole house right
right so will you commit to me and my
friend anthony that you're just gonna
put the bricks down
today yes i will
say it out loud i'm gonna put these
bricks down today
i'm gonna put these bricks down today
and when your husband comes home from
work i want you to give him a
squish of a hug as you possibly can and
i want you to tell him
honey i put the bricks down today i
thought she was gonna say give him a
squishy kiss
you can do that too do them both
do them both and i want you to hug that
baby yes
hug that baby and say honey today i'm
putting the bricks down and you don't
know a mama
who's not carrying bricks around but
today is going to be that day that we
put them down
anthony as parents we've got these
pictures of what it's going to be like i
know you've got them
i have them i don't have any kids i know
but you got a picture of what you
imagine it's going to be
oh yeah yeah okay and it's never that
picture
uh well don't tell me that i i want to i
don't want to think like that right now
i want to enjoy the picture i have in my
head but hey here's the thing
you're going to enjoy the reality so
much more
you're gonna enjoy the reality so much
more it's never what we think
and it's always harder and more messy
and more beautiful yes sir
this is the dave ramsey show
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.org
to find out more
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
doloni joined with
ramsey personality anthony o'neil my
co-host
825-5225 let's go to luke
in janesville wisconsin luke what's
going on man
hey gentlemen how are you doing today
outstanding
how can we help great well i don't
exactly have a money question
uh i mean it sort of is i guess but not
really
um i've been engaged to my wonderful
fiance
for about a year we're planning on
getting married
in june of 21.
and the issue i'm having is that my
parents
don't really want to uh accept the fact
that we're together
and that we're gonna be having a future
together and that we'll be married
um my fiance's parents have been very
supportive
this whole time and i'm very fortunate
for that that
like every time that i've spoken on the
phone with
my folks in the last year like they've
never even asked about
my fiance or how she's doing or
anything it's so they they're very um
fascinated with my life and how i'm
doing but they never ask about
my fiance so the issue that i'm having
is
uh first of all i i want them at the
wedding because it's uh you know
getting married is you know one of the
best days of your life and you want
family to help celebrate that
but at the same time i'm thinking well
long term in the future if they won't
if they won't even say her name now
and what's to tell me that they're going
to be supportive you know
20 30 years from now in into the future
why don't they like your fiance
i don't know that's a million dollar
question you have some inkling like my
parents like my wife
way better than me way better yeah
well that's not hard that's a low bar i
get but yeah
you have some inkling your mom has made
some off
offhand passive aggressive comments your
dad's been passive
like what what is it about her or at
least guess
well i i don't think it's anything
specific about my fiance
now i've i've dated other people in the
past and
it's been the same it's been the same
thing every person that i've dated
so are you the precious little son that
nobody will ever be good enough for you
i think that's a big part of it i mean
i've got one other sibling
okay so here's the deal here's the deal
luke
um save yourself a lot of heartache and
headache
number one if this is the person you're
gonna marry
this is who you've decided to marry it
is what it is what it is
you're doing something called
catastrophizing that's the nerd word
and what that means is you are painting
a picture of what might happen next year
5 years 10 years and 20 years from now
and you're allowing your body to respond
to it right now as though it's happening
and one way to cut through all of this
grief
all of the i don't knows and this could
happen in 30 years from now if my
parents don't fill in the blank
is call your dad call your mom
and say we just need to have a hard
conversation do you not like my
fiance or guys i'm marrying her
i want you all to be on board with this
i want y'all to
be supportive of us i want you to love
me and the best way you can love me is
by loving both of us
but this is gonna happen and then you
move on from there
and you may find out that they don't
know how to talk about it they may not
not like her like you think they don't
like her or you may get some real good
clarity that they hate her they wish
think she's the worst person ever they
think you should break up with her
either way you're gonna have some
clarity because when you get that
clarity then you're gonna know
well then i don't want you at the
wedding or
you're going to feel free to invite them
your parents are going to be have have
the permission to have their own
feelings about it but you're not going
to let them dictate it because they
don't get a vote they're not living your
life
right how hard would that conversation
be luke
it would definitely be hard i mean we've
had um when
when i when i popped the question last
december i
i wasn't living near my parents it was
about a thousand miles away so i called
home to tell them the news you know
and uh it was a very very
weird phone conversation unlike anything
that i've ever had with them
uh it was it was more of like they were
they were almost
yelling at me out of anger that why why
i would
do this in my life you know why i would
ask this woman to marry me
it was almost as though i was supposed
to ask them for permission before i did
it which i did not do
how old are you i was gonna say how old
are you man how are you bro we're both
26 years old being my fiancee all right
cool man
here's the savage side of me
if your fiance hasn't done anything to
disrespect your parents or your family
no she's been loving she's been caring
she's been respectful
um and and this is the woman that you
feel
is your wife god is saying move forward
um yeah bro
i'm just saying what i would do i'm not
saying this is the right thing to do
big difference let me say this but what
i'm going to do this is what i would do
um my my my family will get the message
very clearly for me
that this is my wife this is where we're
going
when they ask me how are you doing i'm
saying we are doing well
and until they can respect her then my
family wouldn't talk to me
now i'm not saying you to do that i'm
just saying my family will know
this is a grown man we have to respect
where he's going
and we need to respect his wife because
the last thing you want to do and i
could be wrong here again i'm not
married
i'm not a marriage counselor but the
last thing you want your fiance
soon to be wife to feel like when you
get married is that you don't have her
back
with your family ding ding ding and you
need to
show your family up front like yo
listen i want to talk to you but
now this is my priority this is my
number one family
and you're number two and so it's like
if you can't respect
her that means you don't respect me and
if you don't respect me
then we can't talk so luke why haven't
you had a conversation with your parents
and i'm asking you this because
you're a few months away from being a
married man you're a few months away
from
legally and spiritually binding yourself
to co-create a new future together
and i'm concerned about what the next
christmas is going to look like
when your mom says xyz what the birthday
parties what the
first when you have your first kid and
your second kid and your third
kid you don't seem like somebody who's
able to have a hard conversation and not
even a hard one a direct conversation
this ain't hard at all
and a direct conversation with your mom
and dad why haven't you had that
conversation yet
well i've i've tried to nope no no no
why haven't you had that conversation
yet
i guess i would rather not deal with
their
criticism and i know that's what he will
criticize
his fiancee his decisions his choices
exactly exactly yeah um and i realized
it really it shouldn't bother me i i
can't control what other people say do
one thing
hey luke it can bother you and
you can't control other people's thing
right yeah and so i'm gonna suggest
you're not ready to get married until
you're ready to sit down and have an
adult grown-up conversation with your
parents
huh have a grown-up adult conversation
with your parents about your direction
where you're going to go like anthony
said
i i know we tell this guy john not to
get married because he's scared to talk
to his mom and dad
i'm it's a i'm painting a broader wisdom
picture if you're ready to
join lives with somebody you're also
able to say
hey mom and dad here's who we are gonna
be
right okay yeah no that
that that makes sense is that fair i get
it absolutely
so pretty much what he's saying luke is
go talk to your mom and dad so you can
get married
you know go tell them up front this is
what we about to do
let's talk that's right you know and uh
that's not a hard conversation
if you love this woman you calling her
right now i mean not hurt
you calling your mom and dad right now
and i'm gonna tell you you're gonna have
a conversation to
have with your fiance because she's
absorbed all of this yeah
and she has felt second fiddle to your
mom and second fiddle to your dad too
and let me say this too your honeymoon
night because you step up to your mom
and dad is gonna be real good
oh and then anthony went there this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease
christian healthcare ministries
or chm is not health insurance
but rather a federally approved
exemption to the health care law
it's a time-tested model to help take
care of your health care costs
it's christians helping other christians
by sharing each other's medical bills
adjusting to a new system of paying for
health care
was kind of tricky but that's where chm
stepped in
and they really helped navigate that
water
with the hospital and the payment want
to see if chm is the right fit for your
healthcare needs
check out our website at
chministries.org backslash budget
that's chministries.org backslash
budget it was just such a relief to know
that financial burden was going to be
taken care of
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
deloney with my good friend co-host
mr anthony o'neal triple eight eight two
five five two two five
let's go to haley in dallas texas hayley
good afternoon how are we doing
i'm good how are we all very very well
how can we
um help i am 22 years old and i have
about thirty thousand dollars in
checkings eight thousand dollars in
savings
um i have like a 730 credit score
zero debt and i own two cars um i just
wanna know more about what i can do
to improve my financial financial
situation and what kind of investments
i should start looking at haley okay
let's
i mean oh my goodness i'm loving this
conversation right now okay i'm loving
it i'm loving it i'm loving it you have
thirty thousand dollars in savings
eight thousand dollars in checking 22
years old
are you educated do you have a
bachelor's degree
i actually did not go to college i just
enrolled in real estate
online school oh and
so what do you do for a living um right
now i'm a marketing coordinator at a
mortgage company and i also bottle
service on the weekends
oh come on working hard and uh what's
your debt looking like right now
hear that zero debt come on
let's go i'm getting excited right now
i'm sorry all right you called in for
help not for excitement
um what what is the next thing you
should be doing at 22 years old
exactly what you're doing right now
living intentionally
uh being a good steward of your means
now uh with you having you just enrolled
in real estate school because
you're working for a mortgage company so
this means you want you want to get into
real estate
love it so you're going to cash flow
that part all right are you doing
any kind of investing right now
i'm not okay so my money's just kind of
sitting and
saving so i want to do more
let me ask you this question too and i
mean it's paid for but why do you have
two cars
um so one of my cars isn't in so great
condition it needs a couple of things
but
then my other cars just i have an audi
that i bought in high school um
cap and then i just this year bought a
toyota because
bottle servicing i drive 40 minutes and
i wanted a
yeah i love it love it love it uh sell
that car today
sell it go go sell the audi don't don't
try and fix it
uh just sell it someone will buy it from
you put that money into your savings
and what i would do haley right now is
the very first thing i would do is i'll
go ahead and open up a growth stop
mutual fund
which is covered by ra so you can start
investing 15
of your income into that okay that's the
very first thing that i would do now
there are some other options as well
that
with your age and with the kind of
income that you're making right now the
income you're about to be making when it
comes to the real estate
uh space uh you can really start
investing into some other different
areas
i would encourage you to speak to a
smart investor pro okay
i just go to daveramsey.com type in
smart vessel right there and
and you'll find some areas not some
areas but some people in your area that
will sit down with you
but one of the key things that i'm
seeing with real estate agents they're
not doing a real good job
of saving and investing their money for
retirement
okay and so what i want to encourage you
to do is to really jump on the phone
with a smart investor pro
go ahead and just tell them hey i want
to open up a uh ira invested into a
growth stock growth stock mutual fund
um i want to start maxing that out and
then what are some other options that i
can be doing at this young age with you
doing this at 22
if you can do this sometime next week
before thanksgiving
and give yourself a good 30 to 40 years
haley
just from your investments alone you
will be a
multi-millionaire now i think you're
going to be a millionaire just from your
income and how you can be doing in the
real estate world
but just think about it if you're if you
can get your income to a million dollars
a year
and then you have investments worth a
million dollars a year at 40 years old
man you're going to be in such a great
place so that's the very first thing
that that i would do
is one continue living with
intentionality
continue being a good steward of your
money continue living below your means
because it sounds like you're living way
below your means i want to commend you
for that right
and then four start investing as much as
you possibly can
into your retirement not just into
accounts for five years
no have a strategic plan um about
that um you know this is what i want you
i want you to hold on
i love giving away people stuff i you
you don't have like a big big book just
yet you're redefining she ain't ain't
just about nothing so we got
i'm not gonna give her your book but i
want you to hold on haley uh because you
are a future everyday millionaire
and kelly's gonna give you a copy of
chris hogan's book everyday millionaire
and i want you to
read this book okay this book is going
to show you what millionaires
are are doing and what they did to
become a millionaire
if you can have that mindset at 22 years
old oh my goodness
so hold on a phone hold on the phone hey
i'm so proud of you
uh hold on the phone kelly's going to
take good care of you man but
john 22 what were you thinking at 22
not that what about you
oh man 22 i started thinking like that
but i was
in debt like crazy
i wasn't even close to thinking about
nothing like
22. yeah i mean i was you know i was a
basketball coach i wanted to win
basketball games and
you know it looks flashy and this is one
of the things
maddie and i'm not trying to plug myself
but i am trying to plug myself here
plug it um this is why i'm so passionate
about helping young people understand at
20
in their young 30s that if we can shift
our mindset
and really start thinking about the
future by being a good steward today so
we can have something to stand on
tomorrow
and build on tomorrow our world is
so so so much better and one of the key
ingredients to really building a life
for success
is identifying your why now a lot of
people hear this but have heard this
before
but like if your why doesn't make you
cry that's what everyone hears and you
don't have you don't have a deep enough
why
but i want to go a little bit further if
your why doesn't make you cry
then the price of commitment will make
you cry
and so one of the key things i'm trying
to teach young people is get that deep
why why do you want to be successful
what's going to get you
over the hump of when people tell you
you're not making smart moves
you need to get this credit card you
need to be in debt
you need to have this you need to have
that no if your why is not deep enough
then you're going to fall into that trap
this young lady has a clear why that's
why she was able to have
thirty thousand dollars at 22 years old
sitting in the bank account check this
out
with no degree no degree i was gonna say
with no degree
no degree and so this is what i'm
talking about on my show
uh the table with anthony o'neil on
youtube
it comes out every monday about to
release a podcast so i want young people
parents if you hear me right now
my show ain't for you i'm gonna be real
but if you're in your 20s and
if you're in your 30s if you know 2020s
and 30s 30s
they need to go over youtube.com because
that's what i'm trying to produce
other young people in their 20s and 30s
really becoming debt free having a
strong savings and building
strong wealth so we can change
the future that our younger people
coming up
can see i love it and speaking of young
people going to get it
this doesn't have to just be young
people it just happens to be a lot of
the time
yeah do you know we have over 130 people
on our creative team here at ramsey
solutions
lots of brilliant minds creative people
i saw what they did with my photoshop
they took a picture of my face
anthony they made me look handsome bro
they made me look handsome too i thought
that's a lot
of creative energy in one space we act
as one big an
in-house agency that supports all types
of business units
our team is currently looking for
passionate product designers with strong
visual design skills and a background in
user experience and user research
if you've been impacted by our mission
and want to spread our message of hope
if you your 20s 30s you want to change
your trajectory yes
we want you to apply for a position on
our team today
find out about all the available jobs at
daveramsey.com
careers we are doing work that matters
and we have more fun in this building
than any job you can imagine and man not
just in this building even outside
brothers
i can't men listen battle the bands
every year
just getting around the fire pit folks
going to hang out at different cruises
people coming over to each other's
houses we've been voted by one as one of
the best places to work
in the country in the country by inc
magazine
young folks old folks any creative
person you get to work with dave ramsey
john deloney rachel cruz anthony o'neil
ken coleman christy wright and even
chris hogan come on apply today at
daveramsey.com
careers get it folks this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture is psalms 20
verse 7. some trust in chariots and some
in horses
but we trust in the name of the lord our
god
simon sinek says vision is the ability
to talk about the future
with such clarity it is if we are
talking about the past
vision is the ability to talk about the
future with such clarity
it is as if we are talking about the
past
hold on let me hold on to that i like
that quote i like that quote all right
let's go to kaylee in hoboken new jersey
kaylee
how are we doing doing well thank you
both so much for taking my call
you bet thanks for calling what can we
do to help i have a question
on how to approach investing with my
fiance or discussing all
our future investing we're both 27 years
old
graduated from state schools debt-free
and have each about
i feel like a hundred thousand dollars
in our retirement accounts and some
personal investing so i think we're
doing great
but his strategy is much more single
stock focus because he works in finance
and kind of thinks that he
you know he's smarter than the indexes i
guess
and i'm much more about mutual funds and
and being more
i guess safe with my investing and i'm
trying to get him on board
for a future because i don't want us to
argue about how we should be handling
our money
once we're married yeah yeah this is
this is a good question right here and i
wish her
uh i wish he was on the phone with you
um do you all
um seek guidance from a financial
advisor
or is he your financial wizard
um no we both use um people that our
families used
okay okay that's prague yeah that's
probably
don't use who your family use use who
you two need to use
you understand what i'm saying so this
is what
this is what i want you to do i want you
to ask your husband hey can we
together because i love how man we are
young we're investing and we're winning
right now financially
but i just want to talk to like a
different financial advisor
that can really just really help us get
to that next level like yo
husband can you think about us being a
multi-millionaire he'll get excited
don't say anything about i don't like
how you're doing single stocks just say
hey
i really want to go sit down have coffee
with someone show someone our portfolio
and see how we can flip this portfolio
and make it even better
and then let the financial advisor from
there
advise you to on like hey this single
stock route is not the best route
mutual funds stuff like this is the best
route and so what i would do
if he says yes then i would just go to
smart vessel pro
and just find a a few of them in your
neighborhood see which one you are
comfortable with
and sit down have the conversation
because i think
we can give you all the stats on the
phone and then the last thing i want you
to do is go back to
your husband say well anthony and john
and dave said
well you don't want to tell another man
what another man said
okay absolutely right yeah so i don't
want to set you up to lose because as
soon as you say well anthony said
well who the heck is anthony
in his house so i would say hey i enjoy
this
i love what we're doing we are winning
right now
um are you open to sitting down with
another financial advisor
and literally having coffee having lunch
with them
and allowing them to talk into how do we
make this
even better and from what i think about
your husband
i think he's going to be totally down
with that uh because it just means
it just means more money y'all's pocket
down the road and then allow the
financial advisor
to call out like hey single stocks
that's not the right to go because
nearly 70 percent of people
who invest into single stocks lose their
money you do not want to be in that
stat okay so that would be my
recommendation yeah i love that and
i love anthony you told him going to a
finance guy
who's won the last few years and said
this i know it feels good
i know we think it's always going to be
raining yeah but there's going to be
seasons of drought
yeah he's not going to hear that yeah
right he's not going to hear that no
and so the answer to this question is
often less a math problem and more of a
heart problem yeah
and i even want to say this too dr ian i
want you to answer this question because
this is our second time
today um you know just hearing this
question
and i hear this often and i'm like man
we got to say something because i don't
want to
i want people to feel like i don't i
don't love my own leader dave ramsey
but the last thing you want to do is say
dave said
right you know you got to figure out how
to get your
partner or whoever you're trying to talk
to your loved one on board
because that's what you passionately
feel you know about
you can say i've done some research i
listened to the dave ramsey show i read
some books i've done this
and i think this is the route to go
without saying
dave anthony chris dr john
said like you got to be passionate about
it
right dave wrote the plan right right
dave lived the plan has created the plan
yes but dave's not waking up in your
house every day come on
dave's not going to be sitting on the
front porch of your paid off house
while your grandkids are running around
in the yard you are
yep right yep and as you talked about
earlier you have to be your why the
picture of where you
and your spouse are going to live
someday that's got to be your why
not just because dave said so now it's
fun when both you and your spouse are on
board yes and you're living it in it's
fun to blame dave for everything
yeah my little brother he is him and his
wife have been grinding for years
he's got all these weird odd jobs he'll
text me from under a picture from
underneath the house and he'll say
look what dave's making me do it's it's
part of a family joke right they're on
it together
but his wife's not coming home saying
you're going to do this because dave
said so yeah
right yeah then you're using dave as a
weapon
yeah instead of as a as a guide as a
path right exactly
that's right all right let's go let's
get one more let's go to joe in
philadelphia joe
good afternoon how can we help hi how
are you
so good so good um
so i've been actually working in the
last couple years on the debt snowball
but i read in rachel's book
a couple years ago and recently our
situation changed where
my husband's father-in-law or his my
father-in-law
he passed away and left us a great
you know deal of uh money so
our situation kind of changed where you
know we're gonna have
the ability to pay the rest of our debts
off and
we have money that we're going to be
able to have in our investments
that are like we're trying to get rolled
into investments but
we still have a mortgage on our home and
uh the financial advisor when i
she asked me what i want to do i said i
want to pay my house off and she
absolutely said no of course she did
because she's not going to get any
of the commission off the rest of them
yeah that's exactly how much do you owe
in the house uh joe
co260 okay um but we would have 700 000
in investments
and um we actually have more cash other
than that we would even have so i feel
like i should take that cash pay off the
house
pay off the house i mean without even i
want to breathe easy at night
yeah yeah and joe if if there's not some
significant ties here
i want you to get a different yes um
financial advisor this is somebody that
doesn't have your best interest in
in mind this they have their best
interest in mind
and i want you to find someone who is
going to sit down and listen to you
and learn your goals one of which is to
be completely debt free
one of which is to honor your
father-in-law by being a good steward of
this money
not that's going to make them a quick
return joe is this a smart
smart investor uh
a what is this is your financial advisor
a smart vester
i'm not quite sure i can tell you no
anthony because they wouldn't ask that
kind of question so what i'm saying is
joe
that's great i want you to go to
daveramsey.com find you a smart investor
on there that you can
explain all your dreams to they will
guide you down the right path and they
will also tell you
pay off your home you have seven hundred
thousand dollars in investments
you have extra cash on reserves you are
on the right track
one of the key things we found when it
comes to building wealth and chris
hogan's
um study on everyday millionaire was
they had a paid for
mortgage okay so buy
pay off the mortgage get rid of this
weird financial advisor that just wants
to commission check
and go get you someone that's going to
help you build true wealth and what
they're going to do is they're going to
say
listen interest rates are 3 i can make
you this much percent
in the market yeah and they're gonna
they're gonna punch some numbers on the
10k and they're gonna say ccc
this is an easy math problem and what
you're gonna say is i'm in this for the
long haul
this is a heart issue yes it's a
psychology and a spiritual issue
it's not always a calculator issue i
want to thank producer james childs and
associate producer kelly daniel
the wonderful engineers in the booth i
want to thank you my brother anthony
o'neil hey man thank you
wish everybody a wonderful thanksgiving
season
this has been the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
you